processes in the state do not
necessarily have any bearing on what
we're doing uh this evening uh why we
start in Iowa is very simple we're not
supposed to pick the next president of
the United States He I hear that all the
time well Iowa is not very predicted
we're not supposed to be if we were
predicted why would we need 55 other
contests in order to determine who our
uh nominee is we are supposed to provide
a framework a neutral framework that's
why I'm neutral in the process and why
our governing board is uh neutral in the
process in order for candidates to come
here and declare themselves uh
candidates for president United States
in pretty reasonably priced media
markets in order for them to actually
run for president and then through all
of you and you're reporting on them and
through any advertisements anything else
they do then they throw their hat in the
ring and do that that's what Iowa is
supposed to do nothing more nothing less
43% of the time the winner of the Iowa
caucuses has become the nominee for for
the Republican party but if
tonight the candidates here believe that
they have had a fair process they have
been heard and I think every one of the
candidates will will tell you that in
terms of their uh in terms of their
relationship with the Republican party
of Iowa then we will have done our job
before any votes even come in so I want
to make sure I correct that very very
clearly that we are not supposed to do
that I know sometimes other states get a
little carried away we're the ones that
pick the president that that's that's
not what the car out system is all about
the car out system is to kick off a
system with 56 different Contex so I
wanted to say that uh first second of
all I want to talk about the
transparency of our Pro of our process
you will find no other place in the
entire country I don't mean that as a
metaphor that is more transparent than
what's going to happen here tonight you
won't find anything more transparent
than what's going to happen here tonight
the votes are counted in front of the
crowd that cast the votes those votes
are reported either via app or via a uh
a phone in front of the people that cast
their votes candidates can have someone
watch that process of counting and watch
that process and if that's not enough
for you after we put that up on the
board I'm sure all of you are going to
be checking out our website the people
that are still sitting in that precin
caucus can check to make sure what they
voted on and witnessed the counting and
what they uh what they witnessed in
terms of putting on our app they can
actually see it reported and then if
that's not enough for you we have a
paper trail of the schedules of where
those votes are counted and we pick up
those votes and the and the hard copies
and we save them and we try to do that
and you know sometimes there's a reason
to do that faster but typically we give
ourselves 48 hours to pick up every
single one of them
1,657 so there is there is I'm not going
to come back out here later on tonight
and declare a winner I don't have to all
of you are going to see exactly what I
see there is not one single thing that I
see that the Press is not going to see
so that's the process that we have
tonight we're very proud of that
particular process I think starting out
everything like Iowa does I think it
needs to be like that I think it needs
to be that
transparent so I those are the those are
the two things I wanted to say most of
all I'm excited about tonight I think
you're going to see iow and step forward
uh we've got some cold temperatures but
this will not be the first U Subzero uh
evening that we have in the state of
Iowa in the winter I'll guarantee you
that we're very very used to this kind
of thing and uh thank goodness uh we're
not going to have white outs or blizzard
likee conditions and we've also had our
great uh work Road workers have almost
two days to clear things out so we're
really excited but
1, uh
657 precincts is uh and that's who's
going to report rep and you're going to
see every one of them broken out triple
quadruple checked for the acuracy of
those numbers so I again you you
probably already know all the caucus 101
I'd be happy to uh take any questions if
you have
any oh they come on
up okay bring the mic to
yeah what's your response to you know
perhaps a candidate denies results of
the caucus tonight or um you know
disputes any of the results what um what
would you say to that well if it's a if
it's if it's what candidates are saying
I have no control over that but what I
do have control over is the process it
will be impossible for a candidate uh uh
to question a process as transparent as
us because every single person in the
world can see what I see and can look at
the paper trail so that what I'm in
charge of what I'm responsible for as
the Republican party of Iowa chair is
the process and that uh and that process
is as transparent as anything in the
country um yesterday you had said that
your optimism about turnout tonight had
rebounded you alluded to that uh just a
few minutes ago as well could you give a
an an update on the number that you're
expecting tonight well I'm not going to
give a spec a specific number that's how
I get myself in trouble but the the
record is 186,000 you all know that I'm
sure and I I had said ear ear uh before
the weather conditions that I I think
the environment this environment still
does honestly right now this environment
still feels like 2016 when we had a very
competitive election and obviously
that's when we set the record um you
know I I I'm thinking that
uh it would be hard to set that record
but I do think we're going to have a
very very robust turnout for uh for
subzero uh temperatures so I still feel
very very good I think the one thing
that's missing and this isn't
denigrating anybody's reporting or
anything like that but I really think
sometimes especially if I'm getting
reports from New York and California and
places that may have never been iow I I
really think people are grossly
underestimating how many Subzero
evenings we have and how many of these
Farmers have to go out and tend to their
livestock and dig themselves out in
order to get to work this is not this is
not an unheard of situation that we have
now I am glad it didn't we didn't have
the caucus to uh I'm glad we didn't have
the caucus to days ago and that that
that was some difficult stuff but if all
we have to deal with is temperatures I
mean you're going to see all the numbers
here before the end of the uh the
evening uh and so in that particular
case we'll see if I'm correct but I've
got a quite a bit of optimism based on a
lot of anecdotes and uh and three
caucuses under my Bell's chair and
probably four others as a participant
before
that uh Jeff hey uh how many people do
you have Staffing the Hall Center if the
app goes down uh we've got I I I'm not
going to I'm not going to talk about
specific uh numbers that we have set up
for things just in terms of
precautionary situations because there
are nefarious uh things out here not you
or not anybody in here but you know what
I'm saying but we are just trust me in
an Armageddon like situation uh we have
uh plenty of Staff well-trained staff in
order to carry this out and still
preserve the transparency that really
not just all of you but the Republican
National Committee and really the rest
of the country uh
deserve
yes uh uh thank you chairman for doing
this uh I have a logistic questions uh
when around what time will you announce
the first Tory uh of the ccus and how
often will you do it inum t thank you
thank you for that question we're in and
we transmit those results to you as we
receive them uh we we have a couple of
processes in order to make sure that
these I mean you would be extremely
impressed if you saw how many double
checks triple checks quadruple checks we
have and obviously for security reasons
I'm not going to outline details of all
of that but just know that I've got
people that have forgotten
more about uh technology that are
helping us right now uh than that that
I've ever had surrounding me before but
as they come in so in a small rural
County or a small rural Precinct we
could very easily have results start to
trickle in in 45 minutes uh there's
going to be other uh and then there's
going to be a slow trickle then I would
anticipate it will build up to a lot of
uh quite a bit of results coming in
there'll be a bit of a bottleneck there
and then we're going to I mean it might
be midnight till we have every single uh
piece of data come in but every piece of
data the first one all the way to the uh
to the to the 1600 plus is going to have
the the degree of transparency and the
degree of Integrity that you expect and
we will track every one of them down and
there will be a paper trail for every
single
Precinct over here uh you know in terms
of the divide in which for covered roads
and everything like that especially in
Eastern Iowa some of the roads are still
covered should we expect potentially
results later in that area would we
given that expectation of have you been
in touch with the Department of
Transportation on where maybe the
problem areas are still sure sure I my
I've got a I've got my little grandson
out in Eastern Iowa who's ninth
generation in Sugar Creek Township Cedar
County Iowa so we and I so I've got
hundreds of relatives spread out all
over the East and I wouldn't just rely
on that because not everybody has that
but yeah you know I I don't know I I'm
hoping we have been we have been uh
asking people to get there as early as
they possibly can our chairs are are
going to be patient we're a very bottom
up we're not like the Democrats that
have the super delegates and has a
president telling them that they're not
going to be first in the nation anymore
we don't have anything like that in the
Republican party it's all bottom up and
so all of our Precinct chairs and all of
our County chairs in some ways they run
their caucuses certainly with our
suggestion but they run their caucuses
how they see fit so I'm expecting that
all of those chairs are going to be
patient with people coming in and
certainly I would rather get those
results later than have anybody hurry up
Beyond where they feel
comfortable have have you heard any
examples of um precincts that had to be
changed because of weather or heat going
out and are there any protocols or
safeguards you want to put in place for
future caucuses uh in case you do have
uh you know another blizzard or uh bad
weather so you know how to respond next
time sure well I think we're responding
next time the way we're responding right
now uh we have
1,657 precincts we have I that for
Generations have witnessed these cold
temperatures I I'm I'm perfectly
comfortable with what what is going on
right now um as far as what was the
first part of that
question closures what was the first
part of closures oh oh I you know what I
I don't know we've had some some
locations changed and hopefully you
found them I mean we pronounced them to
everyone I'm not sure we've had closures
based on weather no we have not had any
closures based on
weather anything
else no well I uh I appreciate all of
your interest in Iowa I appreciate you
being here I hope you felt welcomed I
can't do anything about the weather I
know it was a little bit cold for
everybody but uh once again welcome to
the state where you will not find any
more transparency in this and remember
this isn't New Hampshire this is South
Carolina this is a party run function
I've raised every dime the party has and
we have run this uh on as a party and so
we're very very proud of this this is
the reason why Iowa so thank you very
much and I got to get down there to make
sure everything runs smoothly so thank
you
for
e